when I called my mother and I said I'm
dropping out of University and I was
shoplifting those pizzas at 18 years old
to feed myself it was like survival like
I was either going to be successful or I
was going to be successful there was not
a plan B option the guest that we have
today on the podcast is Steven Bartlett
and he's one of the biggest names in
business right now Steve went from being
a completely broke College Dropout to
founding a company called social chain
which he then sold for like ludicrous
amounts of money he was the youngest
ever dragon on BBC's Dragons Den which
for the Americans in our audience is
sort of the UK version of Shark Tank and
he's also the host of the ridiculously
popular podcast of the diary of a CEO
that has interviewed all sorts of really
successful celebrities and famous people
and also me I've sat with so many people
and thought I will never be as good as
you at what you do I wish I was capable
of it but I'm able to separate out my
admiration and my aspiration and Steve
is also a successful author he's written
a book called happy sexy millionaire
that I've talked about on this channel
and he's just released his latest book
The Diary of a CEO the 33 laws of
business and life we talk a lot about
the things that made Steven successful I
spent maybe 3 to to four years working
in call centers I could have gone and
got a more glamorous job but choosing a
job at that early age that was focused
on my Knowledge and Skills is the reason
why I was able to launch businesses and
do well at a young age we talk about
some of the principles the strategies
the mindsets and the tools that he's
learned through his course of building
multiple eight figure companies work
life balance is a loot of nonsense right
it implies that you're trying to balance
the scales you're not you're trying to
find Harmony which is where you feel
good about your life Sten
welcome to the podcast how does it feel
to be in that chair this is a very
unusual place for you to be it's so
weird genuinely it's so weird it's funny
because before we started recording I I
asked you I asked if my chair was lower
because there's something about looking
at this Frame which I find quite
daunting even though it's like my frame
and it's my you know my backdrop it's
daunting but I'm I'm here for it I'm
excited nice I'm so looking forward to
diving into into your story because
you're normally the interviewer and I've
been wanting to ask you a bunch of
questions for the last several years
since we first met oh gosh I feel like
I've got I've got my chance um so to
start with for the two or three people
in the audience who might not know who
you are I wonder can you tell us a
little bit about the backstory and in
particular I'm Keen to hear about what
your school and University years were
like yes it's called an unconventional
path to success I moved to the UK when I
was a baby from Botswana I was born in
Botswana in Africa my mother's Nigerian
my dad's English so my mother's black
and my dad's white they're very very
different people probably the total
opposite my mother didn't get an
education in Africa I think she left
school at 5 six seven years old can't
read or write my dad is an academic um
who went to you know smashed every exam
he was that was ever put in front of him
so I'm somewhat caught caught in the
middle in many respects of who I am we
moved to Plymouth in the southwest only
black family and the poorest family in
the area and in my school pretty much
huge insecurity and shame they stopped
parenting me about 10 years old which
creates this huge void of Independence
and in that void I start experimenting I
learn a lot about myself and what I'm
capable of and that's kind of a
consistent theme through my life school
I decide at some point and I think
because my two brothers Jason and Kevin
are geniuses that this implicit
narrative that school and grades will
correlate to your
outcomes I believed it and so I knew
that going to school wasn't going to be
the way that I got all those things that
I wanted to get Financial Freedom all
the nice stuff in life um so I gave up
at about 14 15 years old I remember the
conversation with myself where I
realized it was going to have to be
something else and at the time I was
running these little experiments in
school with businesses and they were
working so my thesis was when I'm older
these are going to be the adults with me
so that the party that I organized the
vending machine deal that I did these
would be the adults with me so I'll do
that when I'm old and that will be
enough for me to get there go to
university after being so I was expelled
from school um by Mr let's call it Mr T
and then I was unexpended by Mr sprinkle
um he actually said this on TV a couple
of months ago he came on what I lie to
you walked down the stairs and he said
on what I lie to you um he unexpended me
because I made the school so much money
I I was doing lots of deals for the
school the vending machine deals the
trips the school trips the parties and
then I was expelled again in the last
roughly in the last week of school um
for attendance wasn't rude to anybody
always been well-mannered couldn't
couldn't do school couldn't hand in
homework couldn't listen in class had to
fall asleep in every lesson go to
university believing it'll be different
last one lecture drop out call my mom
mom I'm dropping out she says if you do
I'll never speak to you again I say I
love you too I put down the phone we
didn't speak for many years um at least
not no sort of amicable
conversation uh and then started
businesses and then that's um for the
last 10 years that's been my life 12
years been my
life I've I've been watching your Vlog
recently
and you're constantly jumping from one
thing to another the to-do list with
like 34 items on it by like 11: a.m.
that doesn't seem like the sort of
person that can't like focus in school
or doesn't want to kind of take
boxes yeah I think there's and there's
also often a misconception that I don't
rate education because I don't love
school or university but school and
University aren't education they are
institutions and systems I love
education i f sleep last night listening
to a video about artificial intelligence
and Rockets right I'm I'm a
self-educated that loves education if
you zoom in on that kid that got
expelled what you'll also see is he
stole the psychology textbooks because
he was so interested in them and he
dominated the business class so much so
that Mr Hughes kicked me off basically
like almost expelled me in the business
class because I wasn't letting anyone
else do anything so if you zoom in you
find someone that is absolutely obsessed
with the things he likes and that is
incapable of doing things he does not
like and that is such an important trait
my res my resistance to do things that I
do not like I think is such an important
trait for for us all to try and embody
because what it means is you won't
overstay your welcome in relationships
in jobs in career paths that aren't
serving you and we all have this
wonderful sort of internal um signal or
barometer in inside our chest that we
just ignore we put it at the very bottom
of the priority stack and we put above
it Mom's opinion social expectation what
that girl on Instagram will think and if
that sits above the the signal and I
call it a signal because it is a signal
like hunger or thirst if if that signal
of how do I actually feel sits at the
bottom you will overstay your welcome in
situations that you're not meant to be
in my superpower is quitting with such
ease and conviction and peace because
the signal that matters the most is how
do I feel right now and and that is
useful tuning into that is really really
powerful one of the one of the things
that I um I took away from your first
book happy sexy millionaire we can talk
about the title of that a moment um but
one of the things I really took away was
the quitting framework yeah um I wonder
if you can talk through that for people
who might not have come across it I feel
like you know it better than me but I'll
but I'll but I'll pop it it so the
reason I wrote the quitting framework is
because I realized in hindsight that I
was able to quit things e easier than
most people let's take one step back why
is quitting important in life we
glamorize starting right but my
observation was that the advantage I've
had as I've said was being able to quit
fast and with peace and ease and when
you just think logically about starting
something right or saying it's also the
same with like saying yes and no to
things in order to start something in
life you actually first need to quit
something else so you can't start a new
relationship unless you quit the last
one you're not going to start a new
startup unless you quit the last one um
you're not going to start a new career
career unless you quit the last job so
quitting and starting should be held in
equal regard and there should be
acknowledgement that they have a two-way
relationship with one another they're
both the actions of winners people say
quitting is for losers and they say like
starting is for winners in fact quitting
and starting are both for winners that
and the the most successful intelligent
people I've ever met have an
unbelievable ability to quit things that
make no objective sense you're quitting
that highp paying job to go and deal to
go and do card tricks at table in
Bristol Darren Brown you're quitting
that amazing career as a lawyer um that
your parents are now so proud of you of
to go and spend the next 10 years going
up and down the country in pubs and
cracking jokes Jimmy car it just it
objectively seems to make no sense but
subjectively they've reached a certain
level of ease so I I could relate to
myself in the same way in the regard of
if you look at what I've quit from like
stop going to school because I realized
that that wasn't going to going to be
the the paper that I got at the end of
the process wasn't going to be enough
especially compared to my brothers quit
University after that first lecture quit
my first startup after two years quit my
second one after about six years um and
lots of little quitting in and amongst
there um why was I able to quit with
with peace in at times when objectively
you would think I was a mad man for
doing so when I was leaving so much
apparently on the table and so I tried
to make a framework a framework that
other people could use to try and make
their quitting decisions through so at
the start of the framework you ask
yourself am I thinking of quitting see
the you know yes or no so if you are
thinking of quitting the framework
begins and I created these two
subcategories which you can Define for
yourself which I think is important to
do you're either thinking of quitting
something because something's really
hard like it's difficult and then which
would be you know you're running a
marathon and you're on the 23rd Mile and
you're doing it you know to raise money
for a charity but it's really it's
painful it's difficult it's it's causing
discomfort or you're thinking about
quitting something because it like it
sucks and that's more of like an emot
mental thing it's just it just doesn't
feel good to you on an emotional mental
psychological level so let's go down the
hard route I'm thinking of quitting
because it's hard the first question you
should then ask yourself is is the
hardship worth the rewards on offer so
you're running that Marathon you're
raising money for that leukemia charity
you're on the 23rd mile but it's worth
it the the hardship is worth the reward
at the end of it if the hardship is
worth it don't quit if the hardship
isn't worth it then you should quit
because the the worst thing to do in
life is to do something that is hard and
meaningless like those are those are
where all the problems happen when I
think about studies of the impact of not
having autonomy in your work and working
on a production line and not having
meaning and purpose and what you're
doing every day and how that impacts
your health and disease Rises and your
body that is the worst situation to be
in let's go down the other side of the
framework by the way do correct me
because you know this framework better
than I do spot on and we go the other
side of the framework so you're thinking
about quitting something because it
sucks you're in a relationship your
husband you know the the magic has just
left the relationship you're in a
company and there's problems at work but
you you know you haven't yet had the
conversation with your boss the next
question
becomes do you believe you could make it
not
suck right so in the context of a
marriage um that might mean going to
marriage counseling and having a
difficult conversation and thrashing it
out with your partner and you know going
through those issues if the is no it so
it sucks and you think you can't change
that quit if you believe you could make
it not not suck the next question to ask
yourself is is the effort that it would
take to make it not suck worth the
rewards on offer so like you look at how
that marriage might look if you were to
resolve it you believe you can is it
worth it is Dave worth it is the is the
reward on the other end of that process
to fix it sucking worth it if the answer
is no quit you believe you could make it
nut not not suck anymore but the effort
it would take is not worth the reward on
offer quit if you believe you can make
it not not suck and the effort it would
take is worth the rewards on offer stay
and fight for it and that's my simple
framework which is intentionally
ambiguous one of the one of the laws in
the new book um can't remember which one
it is but it's it's all about the power
of
discipline near the end the discipline
equation yeah death time and dis
and I think a lot of people struggle
with the idea of you know obviously
discipline is good and you know there's
the Muhammad Ali quote um I you know I I
suffered for 10 years to become a
champion what's that effect but then
it's it seems to conflict some of the
time with like this thing that you're
saying of like don't don't do stuff that
doesn't feel good necessarily so like
how do you how do you square this like
what is the balance between I'm going to
discipline myself to get through school
because like the reward of the other end
could be worth it vers is I'm going to
actually quit school and do my own thing
which might feel better yeah so it's
it's so interesting because I've never
tried to make the link but for me
there's a really really clear link
between the two so in the book I started
writing a chapter about time
management which is something you know a
lot
about and the problem I had Ali was um I
I started researching time management
techniques looking up how I manage my
own time and I encountered hundreds of
time management techniques and as I'm
writing this I'm going okay well there's
so many and there's the promoto
technique and the ABC d da da da and the
time blocking technique I asked myself
why is there so many
techniques if if any of them worked for
everyone there wouldn't be so many of
them kind of like fad diets there's just
a million endless list people are
writing new ones because the current
ones are failing them so they're going
in search of new ones and people are
writing new ones um and the reason why
the old ones are failing them is because
they don't have
discipline any of these time management
techniques would work if you could stick
to them you know I say that like
objectively I think they would um so
where does discipline come from and why
does discipline matter and then I so I
started writing about death because I
think you have to there's a really
important relationship between our time
and discipline
because we could choose to do everything
in a world where time was infinite but
it it is the scarcity of time the
limited amount of time we have which I
talk about in chapter 19 of my first
book when I'm talking about the roulette
pieces and the the chips we wake up with
every day we wake up with 16 chips left
out of the 24 we've placed eight of them
on sleep so through that framework it's
important to allocate your time with a
certain intentionality or you might
regret the life you've lived so that's
why Discipline matters because I only
have 16 chips after spending eight of
them on sleep so if I don't want to have
a regrettable life I must need
discipline as I go down my thought
process here I started talking about
death and the fact that if I'm a 35y old
now I'm 30 now but I have 177,000 days
left to live roughly if I meet the life
expectancy of the USA um so I need to
figure out in order to live a non-reg
life how to be disciplined then I
started to examine the areas of my life
where I possess discipline and the areas
where I don't and I was trying to
establish a relationship between the two
why am I really disciplined with going
to the gym now um but I'm undisciplined
in other areas why am I really
disciplined with um I was speaking to
Simon cnic the other day and I was
telling him about this discipline
equation and he was like yeah but Steve
you know I don't love putting the bins
out but at 8:00 in the morning I got out
of bed yesterday and went and put the
bins out and I was like no that makes
perfect sense Simon because the
discipline equation to me is this is
super super rough at the start of the
equation you
have why that goal subjectively really
matters to you like how much that goal
really subjectively matters to you plus
the
psychological enjoyment you get through
the pursuit of the goal y
minus the
psychological dissatisfaction and
friction you get in the pursuit of the
goal so if I put that in the frame of
Simon cynic there and what he said about
getting out of bed at 8: a.m. because he
could hear the bin truck coming down the
road I said to Simon what is the cost of
you not putting the bins out there's two
costs cost a is the bins overflow and
then he's got nowh put his as they would
say garbage course B is you can get
fined so the the reason for doing it is
high at the start of the equation the
psychological enjoyment you get from it
is is super low right and the friction
is high but the Y is higher than all of
it so the equation still balances in
terms of incentives for you to get out
of bed and do it because the you don't
want to find an overflowing bins and
that desire is greater than the friction
is and in the context of me going to the
gym I didn't go to the gym for 27 years
of my life I couldn't find the
discipline to do it I was like most
people like I made the intention I
announced it to the world I failed and I
did that for three years I announced it
to the world I failed and then the
pandemic
happened and I watched as the world was
torn apart because our health outcomes
were linked to our fitness and our
current health and as I watched that in
March 2020 through the screens and
watched Italy be ravaged by this this
pandemic and watched it come over from
Wuhan and then start to creep through
Europe
I realized very unforgettably that there
is this tectonic plate called my health
which I'd never seen shake before and I
was witnessing it shake globally
vicariously and everything I'm pursuing
and care about actually sits on top of
it my girlfriend my dog my cat my my
businesses that I've built my podcast my
everything I care about it's on top of
that so the tectonic plate of my health
is my first priority if you remove my my
my my health you remove everything you
can take my other stuff it doesn't
impact there's no relationship between
them really but the health is the number
one thing and that going back to my
equation you can see how that influences
the equation
suddenly the reason the why for the goal
to go to the gym and work out was so
strong that it outweighed the friction
and since for the last three years I've
gone to the gym 82% of the time which is
six days a week
roughly um and it's stuck and it's now
feels to be effortless because the
incentive structure so clearly um aiming
towards discipline nice um I really like
that equation and as I as I was reading
it um I was thinking that second
component the um the psychological joy
of the pursuit of the thing yeah that is
the one that my whole productivity
philosophy is based around ah um because
for me discipline is
like like having to rely on discipline
to me feels like a negative thing it's
like okay I'm I'm suffering but it's
worth it whereas when I so when I when I
read the chapter about health in in the
Diary of CEO I was I was reading this on
a flight to Florida to attend a Tony
Robbins event and I was in a bit of like
yeah I'm going to read the book and you
had that chapter where you talked about
health and it's it's it's the same stuff
you talk about in happy second it's like
somehow the reminder hit me so well that
immediately I texted my assistant being
like okay I need to take my health
seriously and the system we're going to
put in place is I currently don't enjoy
going to the gym it's not fun I
appreciate that it's valuable but for me
that appreciation that it's valuable not
actually the right direction therefore I
need to make it fun therefore can we
book me a personal trainer and give him
the goal that like three times a week
let's try and make working out fun and
so we've got the first appointment
tomorrow the next one the day after and
it was a direct result of seeing that
reminder where I was like [__] got so
amazing Ally That's so incredible so
amazing because it's a strange thing to
find in this book I think that I think
it's like law number nine about your
first Foundation just remembering that
everything you've done Ali in your life
like same seem for me is contingent on
that yeah Health goes everything else
just dies it's just and then so why
don't we live our life with that as the
first like priority in the list of
things you know if it is the tectonic
play it should be the first thing um but
even thinking about that through the
discipline equation that you can know
something you can know something I was
saying to Rich Ro earlier I know
meditation matters because every guest
is told me I don't do it because when I
look through the lens of the discipline
equation that it's not just about the
equation it's self it's also about how
that then Stacks against your other
priorities so you can have the equation
can be in your favor but in a world of
finite time there might be other things
that are even stronger in terms of
forces of discipline so I know that
meditation is good and I want I want to
do it right it's like there the
psychological enjoyment of it is may be
not huge the friction is kind of high
because it costs your time and stuff
like that and it's a bit hard to just
think of nothing or whatever the process
is so it's like slightly in the favor of
doing it but then in a in the context of
16 chips left when I wake up in the
morning it's not going to win out over
these other disciplines so all of the
disciplines are also competing with each
other to to get into the calendar yeah
and I think when like in in your case
with the health stuff it feels like when
there's a clear emotional trigger that
that's where it takes it from
intellectual knowing to actual knowing
100% whereas for me I haven't yet had
that with health um for some reason and
so F I said this to rich in with
meditation I said maybe I need a little
bit more
pain and I say this to I think I
sometimes I don't always say it because
it's not the most um empathetic thing to
say in certain situations but it's
become clear to me from doing the Diary
of a CEO that change happens when the
pain of staying the same becomes greater
than the pain of staying the same as
they say um and Rock Bottom is a
unfortunately a
remarkable driver of transformation and
changeing people's lives um that some of
us need to to be for the why part of the
discipline equation to suddenly go yeah
you know yeah I think the same thing
applies to uh people who want to sort of
quit their jobs and eventually start a
business as a side hustle all this stuff
like for me when I read the 4our work
week it was an intellectual knowing of
like oh it would be nice to have a side
business but when I saw doctors in real
life absolutely miserable 10 years into
their career and I was seeing them every
day and talking to them and they were
absolutely miserable and they couldn't
leave the job because they didn't have
it money that was when it became like
like sort of deep a a deep within a
grounding of like oh [__] like I don't
want to be in that position where I'm
Shackled to a job I don't enjoy and that
to me was the idea of hell so it's like
that prompted so much action while I was
at University and people would be like
oh you so disciplined you're like
building your business on the side or
editing videos on the side like didn't
feel like it took much discipline at all
it was just like the pain of the the
pain of the alternative was just so
great I'm just like we're going to do
this what I what I hear there as well is
like the distinction between knowledge
and
belief one of them was knowledge the
other one was belief and as I talk about
in the book about like um flat earthers
and stuff like that you can show them
knowledge you can show them information
you know but there's nothing that will
in the case of someone that believes the
Earth is flat the only possible way you
could change their beliefs is if you
took them up in a spaceship and showed
them the Earth with their own eyes
because first party evidence that we
experience with our own eyes whether
it's vicariously by watching someone you
know and care and Trust go through it or
you go through it yourself is the path
to belief change and that's why I say
sometimes like maybe you need a little
bit more pain or there's a rock bottom
you haven't yet gotten to with some of
those more stubborn
beliefs um because all your friends and
advice and the podcast and the quotes
you've listened to haven't been been
enough but also when you think about
self-belief how to how to build
self-belief and confidence same thing
first- party evidence looking in the
mirror and saying like I'm beautiful and
I'm I'm going to be this and that and
the other none of it works as far as I'm
concerned
none of that works it's not stronger
than the seven-year-old that told you
you're a jackass and that what your dad
said to you in the kitchen that time
about your hair like that's a
stronger group of evidence that's
ingrained in your s story so the way
that you counteract those stubborn
beliefs you don't want to have is you
have to go out there and you have to put
yourselves in growth zones where you're
going to be be conf where those beliefs
will be confronted and you'll be given
first party evidence that those beliefs
aren't true knowledge isn't enough
unfortunately it is sometimes when the
existing belief isn't super strong and
stubborn but if the Su existing belief
that like I'm a bad public speaker and I
can't do that is super strong then the
only way to counteract it is with first
party evidence which you'll get from
stepping outside of your zone of comfort
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by hu I've been using hu I've been a
paying customer of hu since 2017 since
my year of medical school when I first
discovered it and basically what it is
if you haven't heard of it is that it is
a meal in a shake it's got the perfect
balance of carbs and fiber and proteins
and fat and it contains 26 different
vitamins and minerals all you do is add
water or milk to the powder usually I
use water you can shake it up or you can
blend it I prefer to blend and then it
becomes a fantastic option if you're
like me and you're kind of busy and so
you don't really have time for breakfast
or lunch my favorite version is the heel
black edition it's absolutely sick 400
calories 40 g of protein for 400
calories I'm trying to get Hench and
it's actually pretty hard to find
something that has such a high protein
content for such a low calorie trade-off
and so I really like using the hu Black
Edition to start my mornings off it's
vegan it's gluten- free it's lactose
free the Black Edition is available in
nine flavors my favorite is salted
caramel and I wouldn't recommend having
every single meal heal because that gets
a bit annoying after a while but it's
absolutely fantastic it's like one of
the meals of the day especially if
you're busy and you're going to kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to £168 per meal for a 400
calorie meal which is just incredible
value and actually way cheaper than
other generic protein shakes on the
market and it saves a bunch of time
because it's so quick and easy to make
and so it's particularly exciting that
they're sponsoring the podcast and
actually we had the founder of hu Julian
Hearn who was on the very first season
of the podcast that was a sick episode
that got so many R reviews as well
anyway if you're interested in trying
out hu then head over to hu.com deepdive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heel.com
deepdive that'll also be linked down in
the video description or the show notes
and thank you so much heel for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by Trading
212 now people ask me all the time for
advice about investing cuz I've made a
bunch of videos about it on the YouTube
channel and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212 it's a great app that lets you trade
stocks and funds and ETFs and foreign
exchange if you really want to and one
of the great things about the app is
that if you're new to the world of
investing you can actually invest with
fake money you don't have to put real
money in they've got a practice mode
where you invest fake money and then it
actually tracks what the market is doing
in real time so you can see had I
invested £100 into this thing what would
my return have been X weeks or X months
further down the line once you've got
some comfort with that then it's super
easy to deposit money into your trading
212 account you can use Apple pay like I
do initially or you can use a direct
bank transfer and then once the money is
in your trading 2 on2 account then you
can invest it in basically whatever you
want now if you're based in the UK you
might be familiar with the concept of an
Isa which is an individual savings
account which is basically a tax-free
rapper that you can put money in you can
put £20,000 in every year up to £20,000
and it resets every April and then all
that money can grow and it's completely
taxfree for the rest of your life and if
you want to sign up for an Isa you can
sign up for one completely for free also
on trading 212 so if you haven't yet
filled up your Isa allowance or at least
put some money into your Isa for this
year that might be a good step forward
also very excitingly there's a new
feature that they've added to the app
which is a daily interest on your
uninvested cash these interest rates may
go up or down over time as the economic
environment changes but the cool thing
is that you get paid out every single
day if you're into that sort of thing
the app also lets you Auto invest which
is a great thing CU then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
AI that will give you a totally free
share worth up to £100 it's available on
iPhone and Android and you can check it
out by typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode I did an interview with
Professor Steve Peters this morning who
I think has been on your pod as well
really the chimp about the chimp Paradox
and we talked a lot about limiting
beliefs goblins Gremlins like the
limiting beliefs that that imprint onto
Us in childhood that is that is so hard
to shake yeah um I wonder for you what
are some of those limiting beliefs that
you still struggle with limiting
beliefs one of my limiting beliefs and I
don't know how interesting this is is
that I believe I'm not
organized and so that shows up in my
life and I've almost abandoned the will
to change
it and as my life has become more
optimized towards the things that I'm
good at there's less if we we think
about the discipline equation there's
less reason to change it there's less
apparent reason to change it so growing
up in my home it was a total mess and
the doors in my house had holes in them
like big holes in them because just over
the years we're just like as you know
four kids in a house parents aren't
there smashed up the doors um it looked
like the the house of a hoarder that's
the environment I grew up in there's
almost something quite deep within me
where today as an adult I feel
comfortable with mess because I grew up
in Mass so I see that reflected in my
behavior sometimes like I'm quite a
messy person and it's a reflection of
home so that's one of them for sure um I
have lots of other like insecurities and
um I think a lot of like hard wide not
enoughness in me that's like deep within
me that's so like I think I think
growing up in you know it's funny cuz at
the time I didn't know it but as I grew
up as I grew up and I became an adult I
looked back on
how I felt going back to that signal of
how you feel growing up in Plymouth in
like 1994 where everyone is white
everyone is
like well most people are doing okay
even my street was like middle class
nice our house was just destroyed at the
time
um and you understand the value of
things by the context in which you see
them so like on a menu if there's three
Stakes um then you'll assume that the
top one is delicious and the bottom one
isn't going to taste good and it's cheap
and you'll therefore usually pick the
middle one if you remove one of those
Stakes decision making changes um in the
same way I grew up in a Street full of
in a context full of white people who
had more money than me so I'd had more
money than our family like the shame of
when my dad was dropping me to school in
that van in the morning praying that the
traffic lights would turn red as far
from the school as possible so so that
no one would see the car we were driving
in all my family
um like all those things you reflect on
those things and how like how enduring
that feeling was throughout my life like
no pretty much I think there was one kid
think there's one kid in the like 16
years that I lived in that city grew up
that knew where I lived imagine that
because when people would droing me home
I would tell them to drop me at the very
top of the hill I would tell them a
different street and I'd get out and
walk k um and then there's no way I'd
let someone at school come into my house
and see that we lived in like you know
in a mess um and you imagine just that
subtle constant desire
to avoid the shame you're feeling and to
fit in chemically relaxing my hair until
I was about 16 years old like if you
look at the old pictures of me we're in
the Vlog you see this kid that has like
ke like I have straight hair and I'm
like this fre cringe and I've got like
the skinny top on with the skinny jeans
all of that shame and insecurity I think
it permeates throughout my life a little
bit I think it's part of my my ambition
and I'm drive and my drive if I'm honest
with
myself I think it's why I've I work hard
and I think it's why I often ask guests
if they're driven or dragged because I
think part of me is being dragged I
sometimes wondered this about you
because especially
like you know you guys have released a
vlog now for three 3 weeks and just like
every time I watch the Vlog I'm just
like wow this guy is Relentless and in
my mind I'm thinking you've already made
the money you've already had the success
you've got the biggest podcast in the
world like what are you doing it
for um so the reason I pause is because
it's very easy to [__] and I don't
want to [__] but it's also hard to
know the answer yeah and I think most
most of us we get used to giving an
answer to that question but what I care
a lot about whether it's true or not and
so I think if I was to Hazard a guess at
the truth I would say it's a multitude
of reasons I would say on one hand
there's no greater feeling than doing
something that people appreciate and
adds value to someone else's life
there's no feeling like the feeling I
experienced this morning when I walked
into the office and the girl that
grabbed me and said I just quit my job
literally this morning I just quit my
job and I told my boss in that job
interview I was quitting and it's
because your podcast I listen to this
particular guest and they help me with
this thing there's no metric that
actually feels like as good for the
human being as that the ego might love
oh we hit three million sub million
subscribers it's funny I walked into my
team that day and go I realized none of
us care that we hit 3 million
subscribers I also don't care it's
important that we use this as a metric
to understand that we've done we've done
well as a team but I realize none of us
care because we're like figing we're
feigning caring who cares if you hit 3
million subscribers it's one more than
two 2 million 9 it's but it's nice to
have Milestones where we celebrate that
matters to me it matters to me that
we're creating stuff that's helping
people that really matters to me on the
other end I do look at the metrics all
the time as I know you do or at least
you did yeah stop now okay okay think we
had a conversation where you you I
remember very vividly you're telling me
that you were like you used to be like
really obsessed with it all and it
wasn't wasn't great it
wasth so that's important that I do I
still have a bit of that in me where
like it matters to me how the episodes
perform in terms of numbers I don't know
I don't know why but um it does I want
the episodes to do really well and I
want I want things to grow and move
forward and get bigger I want that um
maybe that's the shame like the the kid
again trying to be enough um why am I
doing it I believe in life to be happy
you have to kind of fulfill these five
objectives in your profession number one
you need challenge right things need to
be become incrementally more difficult
to the level of appetite that you can
take that's why game in game psychology
every level gets harder you you're not
going to do the same cross word on the
same difficulty over and over again you
would lose motivation Daniel pink his
book is behind you says this they they
do it in studies if it's the same
difficulty people who motivation so when
you're building teams the the thing
you've got to know as a CER or as a
Founder is the depth of difficulty that
every single member of your team is at
and if at one point one of your team
members isn't challenged enough they
will quit you're about 6 months from
them asking for a meeting okay so keep
them one foot out of their depth and I
have this mental model in my head of all
my team members and I actually sat here
this morning with one of them this
morning at uh 9:00 a.m. this morning who
I knew was too comfortable and my
conversation with her this morning was
give me 48 hours I'm going to return you
to the state you were when we working
together in New York where you out of
your depth because I know that's what
you need she didn't articulate that to
me but I know it is I know the reason
why she's like feeling this is a one of
my companies one of my one of my
companies is because she's not out of
her depth anymore Factor number two to
be motivated and enjoy your work
is uh what I call the progress principle
sense of Forward Motion it's one of the
laws in the book as well when they
interview people in work and say what's
your best day in work Harvard Business
Review found it was when it was on days
where people had a sense of progress
this is also what David bford speaks to
um when he entered the British cycling
team many people think of Sir David
bford who took over that down andout
British cycling team and made them the
best to ever do it they attribute the
success of that to the fact that he
cared about these 1% marginal gains 100%
that is a huge part of it but what sir
David brood said to me which I actually
think is more important because it's the
macro Tailwind is when we found those 1%
gains those small ways to improve
something making the water bottle 1 cmet
bigger the pillow softer
the important part was the impact it had
on people's motivation because quote we
felt like we were going somewhere humans
need that sense of we're going somewhere
so if you're a CEO one of the most
important things you should always do
which I try and do a lot with my teams
naturally is constantly remind the team
of the fact that we are going somewhere
it's a feeling in the room and so David
bford told me that when he could get
that feeling into the room of we're
going somewhere because those one %
gains the easiest to find it's hard to
find a big gain in any Pursuit it's hard
to in what you do and what I do finding
those 100% gains it's an accident focus
on the smallest things find it enjoy the
win together which is like oh my God we
just made this 1% better there's a
trackpad glued under the table you're at
right now and the trackpad is there
because me and my team just found a 1%
gain last week where during the
conversation with someone sometimes they
say amazing things and I want to write
it down and just remember it because
that might be the title the thumbnail
the description or whatever and then
after the conversation ends I forget
forget it my team come up and say what
do you think of the episode I don't have
any notes cuz I've had to pay attention
so you'll see a trackpad under the table
where you are now can you feel it is it
there maybe it was the trackpad they
removed yeah there's a little velcro
okay trackpad that we yeah that was the
trackpad so all I do is I just tap it
with my finger and what it's doing is
that system underneath the table is
listening to every word we say and it
highlights it so the AI will highlight
it and send it off to my team so
afterwards I have all my notes and I
just got to tap the bottom of the table
good idea let's do that
it's a great idea but but anyway that's
an example of a 1% gain we found as a
team and when we did that we shared it
with the whole team and and we enjoyed
it and we like this is so awesome and it
created that impression that we're going
somewhere we made progress today that's
Point number two so you need to
challenge yourself need to sense of
Forward Motion number three I'm going to
say is um I'm going to say you need to
be pursuing a goal in your life that is
subjectively Meaningful goes back to
what we said earlier y if you interview
all members of my team and there's
hundreds of people people across
different companies but if you just
focus on the podcast team where there's
25 30 people every single person will
give a different reason as to why they
work here Holly will say it's because of
this I'll say it's because of this will
will say it's because of the the
creativity and his love of production I
don't care what your reason is as long
as you got one yeah so you haven't got
to give them all the same reason you
haven't got to align on reasons they
just got to find theirs and you've got
to help them find their reason so that's
Point number three the the if the goal
is feel sub ly worthwhile to you number
four which is super backed by science we
just touched on it a little bit is
autonomy and control feeling like you
have control and autonomy of your work
when people don't have that in their
work physiologically they're more prone
to disease um psychologically they have
tons of um really difficult challenges
um so having control and autonomy over
what you're doing is integral to feeling
like a free animal that's not in a cage
and last one maybe the most important of
all because we can all recount on times
in our lives where we had the previous
four but didn't have this one in the job
and the work sucked is you've got to be
working with a supportive community of
people that you
like um and that makes all of the other
ones better makes all of the other four
better notice that I haven't said you
know I haven't said a particular career
or a particular you know job or anything
if I have these five things in my
profession Steve will be balanced and
I've applied these five things to
psychedelics where I worked for a year
invested in the company at Thai we took
the company public um at a big valuation
in June 20 2021 I believe um I've
applied it to hu to my businesses to
marketing to software with third web um
I'm applying it to podcasting I guess a
business uh I'm I'm applying it to DJing
I'm applying it to the event businesses
we we run um I'm applying it to my
production company which we're doing
shows on the BBC at the moment um so the
the the subject doesn't matter it's less
important than what people think I think
everyone in this room and everyone list
listening to this now could be could
find their passion in a multitude of
Industries if they had these five things
the subject matter is less consequential
because I wasn't born to be a social
media CEO yeah didn't exist when I was
born so how could I possibly how could
that possibly be my passion but I have
these five things I've had those five
things for a long time as you were
saying those five things those are all
five things that I talk about in my book
as well o cuz it's because mine is
called Feelgood productivity it's about
what are the factors that make work
enjoyable and how do we add more of that
into our into what we do so the
framework that that I use is the three
PS which is power play and people
explain so power is autonomy control uh
Power is also the sense of improvement
and competence like you're getting
better at the thing initially we we
exploded this into like 10 different
things like ah 10's too many to remember
and then it was five because we had
power play people progress and purpose
and we were like oh but like five PS is
a bit much as well and like Dan pink has
already got the uh and then we turn it
into to three 3ps and just sort of
shoehorn in the subheadings in there and
so power play and
people play interesting please explain
play so in um Power I fit in both
autonomy and is it purpose I I fit both
of them into there because you talked
about the thing being something you well
how did you describe it just a second
ago yeah so so for so for us power is um
kind of a combination of taking
ownership autonomy control autonomy
control and also um Improvement like
leveling up prog progress like getting
better at the thing and growing in the
thing gives you that sense of
empowerment of my five you've put
control and autonomy and um progress
kind of together in power yes exactly so
play what's that play is one that isn't
that is an any 5 um play is um
approaching work in the spirit of play
and I think that's not a thing that's
required for something to be for for a
job to feel meaningful but it's
definitely a thing you know that second
that second component of your discipline
equation where the the pursuit of doing
the thing is joyful in itself and there
was so many stories that we found like
Nobel Prize winners Richard feeman who
was burnt out with doing physics and
then one day he sees in the Cornell
cafeteria he sees like a student like
throwing a plate up in the air and he
sees that the logo of Cornell University
is like rotating at a slightly different
rate than like the circumference of the
plate and he's like huh that's weird why
is the logo like wobbling at a different
like than like the edge and he uses that
to model like thermodynamic equations
and stuff and ends up ultimately winning
the Nobel Prize and he says in his
autobiography afterwards that the thing
that cured his burn out with physics
because he'd been doing it for such a
long time in World War II his wife had
died was finding that that sense of play
back in it that lightness and ease that
you can approach work with to make it
feel to make anything that you do feel
more enjoyable so play was a big part in
fact actually plays chapter one in the
book because we're like we really want
to lead with this philosophy that
feeling good makes you more productive
experiencing positive emotions in your
work makes you more creative makes you
less
stressed on the case of Richard Fran
there what was he experiencing in his
work up until he saw that plate he was
burnt out he was the work had lost
meaning I guess yeah yeah cuz he' so his
burnout period was like post World War
II like he'd worked on you know the US
defense thing he worked on like the
nuclear bomb he'd he he he had this
meaningful goal to work towards but then
you know when he got his tenure
professorship he was like uh his wife
had also just died so obviously that
kind of played played a role in it and
he was sort of feeling like ah these
equations that once brought me so much
joy are now like they all feel
meaningless there you go until he went
back to the play thing so if number four
in mine was was subjectively meaningful
a goal that feel is subjectively
Meaningful to you so that's where you
kind of i f that's the play part that is
sort of the play part um our final
chapter is also about purpose um and
just sort of alignment and choosing
goals that align with your core values
I didn't initially purpose was the very
first chapter because it was like well
starting with y but I think the problem
with starting with y which I will talk
to Simon about if I me I think the issue
with starting with why is that it can
often seem overwhelming if someone's in
a normal job that doesn't feel that
meaningful or purposeful you tell them
to start with why and they're like well
there's no there's no purpose beyond the
fact that it's a job and it's like I I
applied to 50 jobs and it's the one that
I got and it's quite heavy to start with
Y in that context and so we instead we
end with why to be like hey once you
once you've done all these things to
make it not suck once you've
Incorporated power and play and people
into your work at that point you've done
everything you can and now let's think
about the purpose
question exactly and if at that point
it's still not working then maybe it's
time to quit the job okay um and then
people is you're point about people how
exciting so you've got power so in the
book you start with play play yeah
Power purpose people yeah I love that I
should have done alliteration so
stupid alliteration makes things so much
more easy to remember [__] okay well
it's publish now so I'm
F it's a good book I've just taken so
many notes I love I love highlighting
Stu which one was you've read both of
them and it's very rare for people to
actually read these books because people
buy them and they just don't read them
like I'm guilty of that which one do you
prefer
honestly I uh
H I actually think they were both very
good at different stages of my life so
the so the two takeaways I took from
from the first one were basically the CH
the time chip thing which I still use um
and also the quitting framework thing
which I still use yeah uh what I took
from this one was a reminder to take
take better care of my health the 11
alsoo laws you have about marketing were
really helpful because I'm I was like
highlighting the [__] out of them being
like sent to yob Senter Al is super
helpful I'm my God like friction adding
friction yes and it's like it was very
specific to business stuff whereas in
the first book it was more General
General Life stuff it's where I was at I
think no exactly it's where you were at
clearly as well yeah so I think it's
like different books hit you at
different times yeah because I'm I I've
never said this before but I like I'm
almost a little
bit shy about the first book now because
it doesn't represent who I am now it's
much more you know Broad and kind of
Lifey and much more kind of opinions and
Vibes whereas I feel like the second one
the new one is much more Technical and
much more like here's how to do it it's
very specific I like the specificity of
it yeah and and like you weren't you
weren't hedging you were like you had an
opinion on each one and I also liked how
you named things and I was thinking oh
[__] I should have named more stuff in
my book cuz you know there was a thing
where instead of using the word
manifestation you called it like uh plan
a be a plan B was the plan a chapter
there's two there's one negative
manifestation like the power of negative
manifestation another one where it's
like plan a thinking you must be a plan
a thinker yeah plan A thinking was like
a plan a thinking what a good what a
good way of repackaging manifestation in
a way because I don't Vibe with the word
manifestation and I suspect a lot of
your audience don't either but plan a
thinking I was like hell yeah I'm a plan
a thinker well you did the whole
literation thing so you you you beat me
there with the whole play Power purpose
ideas from each other because you can't
name my five in terms of the titles
right now but I can name your five your
four play I can do them in order as well
play Power purpose and people or did you
put purpose at the end Pur at the end we
call it alignment like well I remember
yours yeah so that's the problem anyway
uh yeah we spent so long trying to do
like ABCDE e and like autonomy B like C
for competence D for Drive e for
something and it's like can we go to FGM
like no let's just let's keep it simple
I really missed that I really missed the
fact that alliteration is important for
these new ideas and Frameworks that
could have been in the story section the
power of alliteration and the power of
Threes as well you know that whole thing
about like you're you're an incredibly
loyal passionate and empathetic friend
for some reason when something is in
threes PE the brain just I always speak
in threes same we this is our our whole
process for videos for podcasts for
online courses we always think what is
the three part a three part framework
yeah you did that one through as well so
good video podcast online courses
there's there's a line I heard from a
friend who works at uh mckinzy and he
said that the trick that all management
Consultants use is that the client will
ask them a question and they'll say well
there are three reasons and then while
they're saying the first one they'll
figure out what the second and the third
one
are power the power of Threes that's why
we put purpose at the end within
alignment because we wanted three p's
and not four
oh and so we have three in my book we
have three parts and each part each part
has three chapters n chapters in total
guy this guy's got the three each
chapter also has three
subheadings initially we had like four
or five like nope simplify only weird
now it's a bit it's a bit it's a bit too
meta um one thing that
I I have a bit of a burn to pick with
you okay because so I watched your first
Vlog episode and I felt very inspired
everyone on our team loved it we sent it
around to each like oh my God this is so
good inspired us to start a vlog and we
were like yeah this weekly Vlog is a
great idea it's like initially like we
tried daily vlogging like last year but
like daily is too much it's like we we
were scrambling for Content but then
weekly we were like that's a great idea
and so we're very inspired after episode
one and then I watched episode 2 and
then I felt depressed cuz it was just
too good and I was like why why why are
we even bothering like what's the point
our Vlog is going to be nowhere near as
good as Stevens like oh dragon's dead
it's like it's like half an hour long as
well it's like normally our's stuff is
really long and well if he was doing
three minute Vlogs then at least we add
more value but so much value in that as
well and I felt that sense of comparison
and I felt like oh what's the point and
one of the things that you talk about a
lot is as everyone does uh comparison I
think I think in the first book like
comparison is the root cause of our loss
of self-esteem so I wonder if you can
speak to that is is that something that
you that you still struggle with this
sort of comparing yourself to others and
feeling as if like oh didn't do as good
a job as yeah I hope I I now believe
that I do I compare myself to others
again I want to pause to make sure we
all do I think that's the first thing I
have to say is it's human too and I've
thought a lot about this actually I'm
just going to go on a little bit of a
tangent I'll come around the houses and
come
back you when you said that were beating
yourself up a little bit you oh like um
it's important to the relationship you
have with the feelings you have to
understand that all of those feelings
are there for survival reasons and your
body and your mind is not against you
it's very very much on your side the
problem is we live in a world now where
your
body is misaligned with the world we
live in so in the context of
sugar right once the reason why we have
sugar Cravings is
because if if you came across
berries on the Serengeti let's say
10,000 years ago eating those berries
kept you alive so your brain is attuned
to eat more of them the reason why we
struggle to lose weight and lose belly
fat is because the amount of belly fat
you had correlated to how long you had
left to live you know so your body has
this the brain is trying to defend your
weight so losing weight is difficult
because if you go for a big run your
body will then overcompensate with
hunger and make you eat more so that's
why they often say cardio is not a great
way to lose weight you'll just end up
eat more the body is on your side
comparison is important really really
important and useful and it's ingrained
in all of us because we don't have time
to make decisions about things in the
real world so our brain is using
shortcuts and comparison is a wonderful
shortcut to understand what something
means the value of something and it's
hard wide into you to help you to
survive as is your loving of sugar your
need for status um again important for
you to fit into your tribe if you were
kicked out of your tribe then you would
die your body would go into
self-preservation your stress levels
would go up you'd sleep less you'd live
seven years less longer so all of these
things that we fight with we shouldn't
be fighting with ourselves it's just in
case the world has changed and the body
hasn't evolved to deal with it
comparison's one of them it's it's
ingrained in us um we all have it I'm
sure I can compare myself every day to
everybody I meet and I see this guy on
Instagram with great muscles and I go
[__] Jesus what am I doing over here
with this you know I'm doing that at all
times and I have empathy with myself for
that CU it's important to start with a
place of empathy towards that and not
like self- resentment okay so it's
normal to compare ourselves it's not
normal to live in a world where we see
7,000 people a day on a glass screen and
the Brain can't compute that information
it's not meant to it's not normal to
have a fridge the brain wasn't designed
in a world with with fridges do I
compare myself yes um do I how I
interpret the comparison is the key part
so I look at things you've done over the
years and I I go man That's So Dope we
can do that I look at what Mr Beast has
done and go I'm like studying this guy
and I'm learning and I'm going man this
guy's a gold standard and I'm learning
from him and I'm you know I write about
it him a little bit in one of the laws
in the book about the first five seconds
and and I look at Rogan and I go man
this guy just sits there and does no
preparation and then just like talks
about like an ant hill with like this
super smart person or he'll get his mate
on from the comedy club that is insane
how he does that so I hope I hope that
my comparison results in
inspiration and not like jealousy or
resentment or any of those negative
self-destructive unproductive
feelings and I think that can be a
practice I think you can realize that
life really isn't like a z zeros some
game and that like everyone can win um
and that from from them winning they
they can they can teach you something if
you're there to listen most people lean
out when someone is doing well so
they'll like they'll attack criticize or
um or try and diminish that because of
the the dissonance it it creates what
you described there as cognitive
dissonance to some degree like what I
mean by that is when something You
observe is at odds with your sense of
self-identity or what you believe about
the world and it causes the
psychological discomfort of you going
that's really good like we're we're not
going to be able to do that there's
different ways you can deal with the
dissonance one way is you can say yeah
but he's got a team of 30 people that
that is a great way to deal with the
dissonance it kind of like diminishes
what you've seen and it makes it makes
her at ease right he's got 30 yeah but
he's got 30 people or you could say
something else right the harder thing to
do and I think the most important thing
to do is what I call in the book The um
I'm goingon to get butcher his name but
I'll call him the president of Israel
did when Reagan who was his friend went
to that Nazi um burial site and
obviously being being Jewish watching
Reagan who was meant to be your friend
go to that burial site when reporters
asked him you know what do you think of
Reagan going to that where you know
where there's there's Nazis buried and
he says when a friend makes a mistake
the friend remains a friend and the
mistake remains a mistake what he's
doing there is he's doing the hard thing
of holding the dissonance separate like
holding these two facts it separately
he's not diminishing it he's not saying
Reagan's not my friend or yeah but he
didn't go to the barrel site where the
bad Nazis would were buried he held the
two things together and in doing that
you have you you create enough space to
learn and to observe and for nuance
which is rare in this world the thing
we're all doing at the moment is just
diminishing the other side we're not
listening so going back to it if you're
able to hold that dissonance it becomes
really productive and useful for you
which most of us are not not able to do
especially if we have low self-esteem or
we have those other issues because the
dissonance feels a little bit too close
to home it actually says to us I'm not
good enough and that's a very deep thing
to experience in this in the light of
someone else's success for their success
to convince you that you were a scumbag
and that what that seven-year-old said
to you in school is true about your
sense of self-worth is a lot to take so
if you have low self-esteem I think
reducing the dissonance by slamming the
person being pessimistic justifying it
away is much more likely so you
interview a lot of kind of very
successful people do you ever find
yourself in that unhealthy comparison
mode or have you gotten so good at the
sort of comparison equals inspiration
rather than comparison equals envy that
it's just
I've never sat with someone and thought
man I'm so jealous of you but I've sat
with so many people and thought every
day I think I will never be as good as
you at what you do I will never have the
knowledge recall the intelligence the
perspective the articulation I will
never get there I will never be and I I
wish I wish I was capable of it but
I I'm able to separate
out my admiration and my aspiration
they are two different things which we
often conflate I can sit with someone
and go you're the go you're the best to
ever do it you're so much better than me
at that thing and also not then aspire
to become them sure yeah um and I think
actually that's that's because I at this
f chapter of my life now like I'm okay
with who I
am so I can
admire I can admire like I can just do
the admiration part without turning it
back on myself and saying what does that
say about me and I I see it in my some
of my friends one friend in particular
that I have if I said to this one friend
that I have in particular I go they go
like what are you doing to I was like I
just went to the gym
immediately they will actually hear that
as why didn't you go to the
gym so I can't even have a conversation
with them about like oh I went I we had
it yesterday in the car she said to me
um oh where have you been I said I just
ran to the gym and then I and I watched
her face and I she goes I'm going to be
going to the gym
soon and what in that moment what
happened happened is she actually she
heard
my experience and she heard my
discipline or she heard my goal and it
it so where she is in her life at the
moment is she's quite self-conscious and
she's struggling with self-esteem so she
what she experienced was extreme
dissonance which was why didn't she
heard her brain translated it to why
didn't you go to the gym you're not good
enough what I said was I just been to
the gym this morning and that's again it
goes back to the interpretation based on
our
self-esteem for these events that's an
extreme example but it's kind of the
same thing in terms of comparison that's
the extreme example where someone can
just tell you what they did and you
actually hear why didn't you you're
you're not good enough
yeah nice it's good stuff um can we talk
about your buckets so that you f filling
the buckets in the right order um
there's no alliteration there either I
should have done alliteration yeah so I
I really vied with that story um I
wonder if you can you can tell the story
of how how you came to come across these
these five buckets yeah you know the
person that I'm referring to and I have
to say there might be a little bit of
folk tail to this because this person
said it to me and the individual that
I'm talking about is um they're very
good at storytelling but what they said
to me was they were in San Francisco and
might yeah they were in San Francisco
and a sweaty man
came came jogging past and this sweaty
man was kind of like short on breath and
he was explaining like that he was
building rockets and doing these
microchips and these monkey brains and
all building tunnels and all of these
crazy abstract things and then he ran
off and as you hear that story
objectively you go that is a lunatic
that has escaped from an asylum but in
reality it was Elon Musk and the only
reason that when I say it was Elon Musk
it suddenly becomes believable is
because Elon Musk has spent his life
filling these five buckets so Elon could
say anything he could create any
ambition and people would sell their
houses to invest in his ideas because he
is someone who has five full buckets the
last one of which is maybe in question
but five full buckets the first bucket
is knowledge he's committed his life and
there's actually a Side Story to this as
well which is um when I met a famous
monk in New York City I was with
Jetty for the first couple of years of
my life I was dealing with this kind of
mental conundrum as to whether
committing my life to building
businesses which would ultimately enrich
myself was that a worthier cause than me
going back to the village in Africa and
saving just one life with the skills
that I have right like what was more of
a worthy Pursuit so when I was in New
York and Jay introduced me to this Monk
and there's this big room of people I
got to ask one question so I asked that
question I said like if I could go to
Africa and I was like 22 23 was young I
could go to Africa and like commit my
time to saving one life or I could carry
on building these
businesses which one is more worthy
which one should I be doing and the monk
said to me you cannot pour out for
others that in which you do not have
yourself and so what I interpreted from
that is filling these five buckets first
one is your knowledge which Elon
certainly has a very full bucket it's
important context here as well this
first bucket of knowledge is is always
growing bigger there's more knowledge to
acquire it's like a bucket that is
increasing in size as more knowledge is
available first bucket is your knowledge
the second bucket is your skills Nothing
in life can ever empty these two buckets
the the remaining three buckets that I'm
going to describe can be emptied things
can go wrong you can get fired from your
job professional earthquakes but these
first two buckets no one can ever empty
them your knowledge and your skills and
skills are really applied knowledge so
when you learn something and then you
apply it we call it a skill which is
kind of what we've been talking about
with like knowing something but then
doing it is completely different you can
read about exercise but then doing
knowing how to do the squats and stuff
comes from the application of the
knowledge which is a skill these are the
most important buckets in your life
because when these overflow they fill
the other three buckets of your
resources um your network and your
reputation now these three things can
can these buckets can any time and if
you're young and you're thinking okay
which job should I take you should you
should make the decision through this
Frame because I talk about one of my
team members in the very early stages of
my entrepreneurial career who decided to
leave our company because he was offered
a great job title and a big paycheck
which is reputation and
resources but he hadn't filled his
skills in knowledge bucket he' kind of
like managed to convince someone that he
was capable of being a CEO of a very big
company even though he hadn't didn't
have the Knowledge and Skills and it
kind of it's quite obvious what happens
there life will catch you out if you
don't have the Knowledge and Skills to
meet the situation you're in what I'm
fortunate for is in my life I spent
maybe three to four years working in
call centers picking up the phone
calling Dorothy at 9:00 p.m. to sell
like you know artificial grass Windows
Doors conservatories kitchens because it
filled up these this Knowledge and
Skills bucket profoundly I could have
gone and got a more glamorous job but
choosing a job at that early age that
was focused on my Knowledge and Skills
not that paid me more or that had higher
status amongst my friends is the reason
why I was able to launch businesses and
do well at a young age so I would just
impress upon people to really focus and
prioritize those first two buckets
especially when you're young and
especially when they're empty yeah this
is a a thing that I've I've heard from a
lot of um a lot of entrepreneurs you
know I asked the question of if
someone's young and they want to start
their first business what you recommend
and a lot of people say that if you want
to start a business it is very
worthwhile getting a job at a startup
first that has like fewer than 10 people
because you will learn so much stuff and
you're being paid to learn and the
objective of that is for you to just you
know as you you would say fill up those
buckets or or like add stuff to them of
Knowledge and Skills yeah and then when
you start your business you're way way
more ahead of the curve than if you just
quit your job start a business
completely from scratch and now you're
having to fill the the the skills and
the knowledge while also not having any
money coming in that's like a harder
place to be 100% And it's like the
cheapest way to fail right it's the
cheapest way to observe failure we
talked about how beliefs are first first
party experience them yourself with your
own eyes like you saw your doctor
friends unhappy um and we talked about
the importance of like you
know beliefs coming from experiments you
run being outside of your zone of
comfort a startup is that environment
exactly cheapest way to fail cheapest
way to get that information to see it as
close as you possibly can in a big
corporate you might be cloaked from it
so many people so much responsibility
the failure kind of happens somewhere at
the top and it's you know you don't see
the consequence of it and also sometimes
there's not a consequence of it in a big
corporate you know it doesn't cost the
company there the lights um but in a
startup you get all of that without the
failure being you know it's a low low
cost way to fail yeah nice um law 22 you
must become a plan a thinker what is a
plan A think er um I describe plan a
thinking
as really interestingly I'm like making
a bunch of connections here because it
kind of links back to what we said about
discipline and
prioritization you know our time is
competing with a series of other things
that we want to do um the problem is the
studies and the stats show that if you
give someone in a study an alternative
you give them you even let them think
about an alternative they are less
motivated
for
the primary objective so the studies
that I talk about in the book are they
get people to sit down and they say this
is the
goal and if you do this goal you'll get
a candy bar let's
say then they ask the people to do the
task in a second study they say sit down
this is the goal if you complete it you
get a candy bar but just think about
another place here on campus that you
could get a candy bar just the thought
of where else they could get a c Cy bar
distorts their motivation and reduces
their motivation towards the goal so
that the evidence is really clear when
you have a plan B only detracts from
your motivation and your commitment
towards the plan a plan BS are
detrimental in the context of motivation
towards a plan a um and I reflect on my
own life and again I didn't have a plan
a when I called my mother and I said I'm
dropping out of University and I was
shoplifting those pizzas at 18 years old
to feed myself um it was like survival
like I was either going to be successful
or I was going to be successful there
was not a plan B option I couldn't I
didn't have anywhere else to run to so I
think that focus and you know I talk
about um the story of the plane crash in
the book which is always my one of my
all-time favorite stories um that Focus
enabled me it was just 10% more wind in
the sales towards where I wanted to go
and sometimes 10% is the difference it
was just that you know on that day where
it's really difficult and there's so
many reasons to quit and if I had a
comfy place to run to that would have
played on my subconscious and maybe
tempted me to run to run to that soft
comfortable place not having that put
that energy back into the mission and
that's kind of what I speak about when
I'm talking about plan a thinking it's
it's removing the alternative so that
you can use all of your energy towards
the main goal yeah there's a remarkable
power and focus um we've found this in
our team recently like it's so tempting
there's the infinite list of things that
we could do and then we'll be like yeah
let's do all of this stuff and then it's
like we're making 1% progress in like a
dozen directions but when we focus in
like the one or two things that really
matter then we're able to make more
progress in those areas MH and so one
thing we've now done we work in six week
cycles and every week uh every every six
weeks everyone on the team just picks
one Quest the the one thing that they're
going to do in the next six weeks that's
going to move the needle in their
particular area which we we we found
super helpful um I love that again when
I when I look at your Vlog and and what
you're up to doing loads of different
things um you've got the various
companies you've got the podcast it
seems like you're out at like random
times of the night three podcast guests
in one day and then like a 3,000 people
like in the evening there's a lot going
on how do you think about where you're
spending your energy and focus so I have
to say that I'm struggling with it so I
think it's important because I think I
think it's important to be honest like
I've overextended myself definitely in
my life I've done I've taken on too many
things which probably means six to 12
months ago I said yes to things I should
have said no to I like deferred them to
a future Steve who I didn't appreciate I
didn't appreciate the context he was
going to be living in so I've definitely
overextended myself um I definitely
struggle with it I can do it in bursts
but I can't do it consistently I can't
be consistently intense so this chapter
of my life is very intense I came off
the back of Dragon's Den problem with
Dragon's Den is it can takes my all my
time away so everything has to fit into
the residual time and the residual time
is is n enough to record my podcast to
run the businesses to invest to do all
the things I have to do with in media
and what whatever else so I'm struggling
with it um the struggle means sometimes
I'm falling asleep at 3:00 a.m. and I'm
like I'm tense I'm like there's like an
angst to me like I'm tense my brain is
and then you know I'm trying to have a
relationship as well so I'm struggling
with it so there's a problem here so I
want I want to say that because I don't
want anyone to think I've got it cracked
um the important thing that I can do to
control it is to have a clearer
framework of of what I say yes or no to
um which goes back to our discipline
equation thing and also goes back to
this quitting and starting thing like
you've got to be able to say no to a lot
of things in order to say yes to them
saying no and yes have an equal
importance in life and then the bigger
overarching thing which I think most
people are aware of is there's actually
just a few a couple of things that I'm I
should be doing with my time and they
tend to be the biggest things and the
smallest things what do you mean so as a
CEO of a company there's two areas where
you can where only you can do the thing
that adds value so it's like the big
stuff right like strategy and all that
stuff all the stuff in the middle
everyone else can do there's people that
can do that and then the small thing and
I say small because it seems small not
because I think it's small which is
going over to berta's desk and saying
happy
birthday coming from me that means a lot
to but I realized that and no one else
can go over to berta's desk and say
happy birthday from Steve and create
that same impact that I have on her
which is like letting her know that I
know it's her birthday and it matters to
me and that so I do the really big
things and then I do the really small
things and also within that there's I
have like very limited amount of skills
this is not me being like humble or
whatever I'm very comfortable with the
fact that most things I'm bad at maths
organization I said to you messy
operational stuff process stuff I'm bad
at all of that stuff I never do it I
never try Finance related stuff don't
even look at it not my problem
thankfully my older brother works on my
company full-time now so and he's a math
genius as I think I explained earlier
but there's this little thing here where
that's me that's where that's the thing
that Steve is good at and that should be
the thing where I'm allocating most of
my proverbial chips in a day my 16 well
let's say I'll give 9 hours let's say
I'll give 12 hours to work a day my I
should spend spend those 12 chips in
work doing that thing that only Steve
can
do which is hard to explain but it's
kind of like linked to marketing it's
really an understanding of human beings
and like um
yeah and vision Vision stuff like
knowing knowing it's a philosophy thing
it's like I talk about the in the
philosophy section in the book like that
philosophy towards work which is the one
perents the
experimentation giving that philosophy
to team of people so that we we we find
the right answers before other teams is
my thing team culture and team
philosophy and then the marketing bits
I'm good at as well but nothing else I
don't need to be good at anything else
because you've got you've got the
podcast you've got flight Story You've
got third web you invest in bunch of
companies which require you to get input
on them and attend board meetings and
stuff like you know we do do a lot of
one a couple of boards that M matter to
me healing company um I did a tie for a
year the Psychedelic business for a year
and then yeah it like my professional
things that are occupying my time and
then dver yeah which you said at the
start which is like yeah takes a lot of
time so I guess my question is why
bother continuing with flight story and
third web and investing and all this
stuff it but I mean from the outside it
seems like Dar Vio is the main thing but
obviously you're less public about what
what goes on with the other businesses
it's a very good question
I have
a disease of I have the disease of
Entrepreneurship and I have the disease
of
self-belief and I have the disease of
curiosity and as those three things
Collide you need an antidote to the
disease which should be focus and saying
no to things and the someday shelf where
I think I talk about my first I don't
even know where I talked about it but
just the Shelf where you have a great
idea and you believe you can do it and
you believe it matters and you just
[__] put it on the shelf and then if
it jumps back off the shelf you pick it
back up and you put it back on the shelf
and then if it keeps jumping off the
shelf maybe for 12 months then you go
okay right guys right PRI priority um so
with that with those three diseases
disease of Entrepreneurship the disease
of self-belief and the disease of
curiosity um when things happen I have a
desire to build in in that area so when
the blockchain conversation began I had
a real desire to build it's the same
reason why I went into a tie life
sciences and spent a year working on
taking a psychedelic bit business public
and learning about all of the clinical
data around psilocybin and magic
mushrooms and Camin and Iber gain and
what going through all of the that
research paper and then figuring out how
I could use that to tell the story of
the mental health movement through the
lens of psychedelics and constructing
everything I remember writing the script
for the IPO video ipoed it's worth 3.2
billion and I was fascin this is what
when I was talking about these five
principles of loving work it doesn't
matter the subject subject is
inconsequential what matters is that um
that I care and that's why because I
have that disease and sometimes I can't
I can't qu quell it so it turns into a
company that's what happened with flight
story in third
web I I love marketing I love psychology
in business I used to steal the
textbooks for psychology and what is
psychology in business it's marketing
that's what it is and with third web I
was fascinated by fascinated by the
blockchain so I built started a company
there called the smartest guy I knew
started tracking to him about it for six
mon once and then that led to third
B if you had let's say I don't know an
extra 500 million in the
bank to what extent would How would how
would you change how you spend your time
such a good
question
um I
would I believe I would and I might be
lying to myself because we'll [__]
ourselves sometimes I believe I would
stop
um okay so if it was right now if you
give me 500 million right now in the
bank um
versus I wasn't currently doing anything
and I was starting from zero two
different answers sure let me answer if
I was starting from zero yeah if I was
starting from zero and there was nothing
in my life there was no podcasts there
was no businesses third web flight three
all of it's gone I would start a media
company that does pretty much what D is
doing and I'd make it um
I would have loads of podcasts all
around the world with lots of different
wonderful creators that I believe are
making the world better and have
important opinions to share and I'd be
running one of the biggest media
companies in the world that's what I'd
be doing because I say this because
doing the podcast is my I a guy yeah and
so I would just do more of that and for
anyone that doesn't know what an i guy
is it's a sort of a Japanese phrase for
when you find the thing that kind of
provides you with the most fulfillment
in life when it meets these four
criteria of and I'm might buter this so
help me here Ali because I know you know
it the first one is something you
believe you can be good at the second
one is something that pays you the third
one is something you enjoy and the
fourth one is something that you believe
is of service to others now doing the
podcast is the first thing I've done in
my life that really feels like that it
feels like it completes the I guy so if
you gave me 500 million and I had none
of these other things going on in my
life I would do more of that okay what
about scenario two where you do have all
all the other things I would take the
money and I would invest it into my
companies I back myself I'd invest I'd
get a hundred million today and I'd put
it into flight story um and make that
the greatest marketing business in the
world the greatest sort of agency in the
world take another 100 million put it
into third web so we win that game we're
playing there within web 3 um I take 100
million I put in D of a CEO um
and within D we have this really nice
philanthropy charitable initiative I'm
doing this initiative with the Red Cross
at the moment called this Cash Card
thing so I'd invest in that for refugees
and disaster stricken areas
yeah I would need the rest I don't know
put it in a bank or put it in a high
growth fund had this um this Tony
Robbins event I was at last week it was
uh business Mastery it was really good
um interesting very interesting from
like a meta perspective of like how he
does events and stuff but also some
genuinely like really helpful like
advice on growing businesses and one of
the main objectives of the of the event
was to take people from being operators
to owners where an owner can have
freedom F flexibility can can their
businesses can grow they can build the
Empire but they've got operators in
place for the various teams and stuff
doing the doing yeah and one of the
things he was saying um was sort of
splitting up people into three
archetypes there's the archetype of the
artist who believe in the work for the
sake of the craft yeah there's the
archetype of the manager/ Leer there's
the person who loves to build systems
then there's the archetype of the
entrepreneur who loves the thought of
building something from scratch and
taking risks and making making all that
happen and I very much resonated with
the artist thing where my answer to if I
if I won the lottery I'm like great all
I'm going to do is learn cool stuff and
make videos about it because that's my
iy guy but it sounds like for you if you
want the lottery you had like the
lottery times five it sounds like you're
more the entrepreneur that you enjoy the
idea of like building companies and
taking the risk and growing them yeah
and I I'm I'm I'm an entrepreneur but I
I can resonate with what you said about
the Artist as well because if you look
at the diio live show where we spent
700,000 and we made £700,000 so we broke
even um it took several months of my
life there was no Financial reward on
offer but I love music same reason I've
I've started DJ a year ago two years ago
now um and I love the creative element
of creating something that makes people
feel something so if You observe what I
do on a daily If You observe the
conversation me and will who produces
the Vlog had last night I mean we were
sat where you're sat right so we were
sat there and what I'm talking to will
about I think a lot is like the
creativity the story arc the art how I
was talking to him about de
at home or like the 16-year-old in
Zimbabwe who clicks on the video and the
experience and the way we want her to
feel and that's like one of the things
that I do in all my companies is I'm I'm
like when you see our trailers for the
podcast or
whatever I'm heavily in ant is the
genius right ant is a genius give him
the credit um but I see every single one
and I and we obsess over every single
one if you came to my live show it's
like I mean how do I describe it 40
person choir on stage with a huge band
and visuals and the new show we've got
sound effects and we I've spent the time
on like the lighting effects to immerse
you so you think you're going through
the seasons of life so the room gets
cold then it gets hot and then um and
the projections across the wall and the
violinist and the orchestra for this
show that we've got and the choir and
I've picked every song and and and how
it all comes together to tell a story
that makes you feel something so deep in
your chest that you want to cry or you
want
stand up and you know almost you know
that's the stuff I love that's the stuff
I love and it links to my love of
psychology somehow um I'm not good at
like drawing or painting so when I
thought of artists I thought of like
drawing or painting or these Geniuses
you see like Fred again who's
like and is like a musical genius I'm
not that but I love things I love
knowing how the things we create impact
humans at a profound and deeper level
if that's creativity if that's what
artists do then I can resonate with that
um when I look at Elon I see like an
engineer entrepreneur when I look at
myself I see someone that like loves
music and and the way that you can
change a story arc to make someone feel
something um and to move them in a way
so my team know it like titles
thumbnails uh trailer stuff story arc of
the episodes any video any of my
companies have ever made for any
announcement ever um I do the story
board I do you know and he's laughing
will is laughing at my team CU I'm like
obsessed with it yeah
so whether I'm good at it or not is
another question but I love
it you know whether I'm good at it is I
don't know but because art is such a
subjective thing but I love that stuff
and I actually I actually never related
to being a creative I never thought I
was creative ever but it's from and I
don't even know if I quite call myself
of creative
yet yeah I don't rbe with the word
creative either i' I've always thought
of myself as optically creative I think
I
just take ideas from sources and connect
them and apply my own synthesis to it
which some people say is creativity but
it doesn't like to me creativity feels
like drawing an art which I've always
been bad at if I wasn't an entrepreneur
the next most obvious thing for me to be
is like a movie
director that's like or it would be a
therapist now there is actually
I I actually
did spend many hours looking for a
course I could do on a psychology degree
that I could do that would allow me to
become a therapist like six months ago
oh not like not like not like when I was
younger I mean like I'm like looking now
for these like out of un where you don't
have to go to the university you could
do it at home because I'm so fascinated
by people and why they do what they do
as you can probably tell if you listen
to the dire of CEO that I thought you
know what it would be good to have some
kind of qualification in
that so if I wasn't a therapist and if I
wasn't an entrepreneur then I would be a
movie director because I loved how you
can tell a story that Mak someone feel
something how you create that story arc
and surprise and yeah interesting um
final couple of things I wanted to ask
you about uh one is that you know
something that I struggle with is that
I'd love to get your take on is when
there's lots of stuff going on um and it
can sometimes like like balancing that
with for example the relationship with
my girlfriend seeing my friends seeing
my family those things that are not in
the work category but the work category
can just take over because of all the
trips and all the cool stuff going on
and all the this person's in town it's
grabbed dinner with them oh no that's
date night like do you find how how do
you manage that balance between the work
stuff which is obviously continues to
explode for you at a ridiculous level
with like real life like friends family
relationship how are you doing with it
struggling uh I am I think I I was
struggling I've I've created rules Like
Mondays and Thursdays is just always
date night and that's non-negotiable
even if like I I've I've I've had to say
even if Elon Musk is in town and wants
to go on a podcast and my girlfriend
can't do like anything other than
Thursday night I'd be like cool prioriti
Rel to my
face myself anyway you are lying to my
face if Elon was in town I want to come
on my podcast I'd be like babe yeah
baby it's got you can come and watch we
can do we can eat while I do it like so
thing I've been trying to figure out
like what are the rules because I find
having rules in place makes it easy to
say yes or no to things yeah but again
it's a it's a constant B it's okay to
say it's a constant battle and you
struggle with it I I I feel the same way
I really struggle with it and I'm trying
to make sure I've got a different
decision framework for different goals
in my life in some areas of my life you
think about
productivity as we would Define it you
know within Society so you think about
productivity and then you can measure it
by certain okrs or metrics or whatever
and then I've learned over time to apply
different measurement framework to my
relationship with my girlfriend which is
no framework at all no no measurement at
all and um and just going back to the
like poker chip analogy the whole idea
of you get these 16 chips if You' spent
eight
sleeping you don't want to you need to
place them intentionally against your
values and the things that matter to you
so we both agree that our girlfriend and
our relationships really matter to us so
focus on the allocation that you're
giving to the thing that matters to you
and make sure it's in balance with the
allocation of the other things that
matter to you and when I say balance
that doesn't mean it's equal but it
means that you achieve
Harmony so balance work life balance is
a load of nonsense right it's a load of
like it's really unhelpful because it it
implies like imposter syndrome is a
really unhelpful frame it implies that
you're trying to balance the scales like
50 50 grams on each side you're not
you're trying to find Harmony which is
where you feel good in this context you
feel good about your life you know you
don't feel like you're sacrificing
anything that's integral to your
contentment and happiness that's what
I'm trying to do I don't have balance at
all I'm not trying to find balance I'm
trying to make sure I'm in harmony with
my relationship and that is an ongoing
dialogue and that's ongoing check-ins to
make sure that Harmony is there um but
it's a struggle and it comes in Seasons
this what a lot of people have taught me
is that you don't have work life balance
you have seasons of life and in this
season of life you might be over
indexing or over prioritizing this goal
more but then when you become a dad Ali
as I'm sure we will both become in the
next you know 5 10 years if we want to
um you're going to go into a different
season of life and then it's going to
shift a little bit and that's okay you
know that's okay and I would also I
think it's important because there'll be
some people that are listening to this
that are like happy workaholic
fine
good because the key word there in the
North Star is the happy word so if
you're a happy workoholic and you
genuinely know you're happy you're not
being dragged by an insecurity that
you're you're you're quenching through
this obsession with work if you're a
happy peaceful content fulfilled
workaholic all power to you you're
killing the
game if you're an unhappy workoholic
there's a problem and you're out of
Harmony um so also have empathy for
yourself if you're a happy where garlic
because the world will try and de
demonize you oh my god Ally you're so
toxic but [__] him listen to the signal
inside of you like am I happy and I
think I'm a happy workaholic and I've
created a harmony with my girlfriend
where our
relationship is good and I and I can be
intense and the way I want to be in in
my work
um most of the time right now I mean
I've overextended as I said but most of
the time as me and we zoom out on you
know the four years we've been together
we're good nice does that help at all it
does yeah it's helpful I think that's
sort of how I think about it as well um
sort of almost like you know balancing
on a tight rope it's it's less about
being rigid but it's actually about like
swaying one way and another way and then
rebalancing when you notice you're yeah
you have a bad week huh you have a bad
week and you'll know you've had a bad in
terms of like you just [__] H I've
paid no attention to each other we feel
disconnected you can you'll feel the
frustrations lingering in the
relationships something will happen in
the bedroom like in the bedroom or the
kitchen and it'll become so much of a
bigger issue but it's actually because
last week you were really
disconnected that check-in process is so
key yeah are you a good communicator
with her um I think we are have
definitely gotten better at that over
time um we have like check relationship
check-ins and stuff which are good
systems cuz I like systems as to she
which is nice uh and you know where we
ask questions like how's the
relationship been for you this week
what's what are three things uh that you
appreciate about me this week how' you
do that oh we have we have an ocean page
with a template this is out of control
it's been going on for the last two
years got the toggle it's actually
really good and she was the one who put
it together rather than me cuz you know
I was it's so good yeah and it's like
you know what's what's one thing I did
that made you feel loved appreciated or
respected and then so the first half of
the review questions are like you know
the nice stuff and then it goes on to
you know what's one area in which you
know you felt I did something that made
you feel a little bit bad even if it's
really minor you know let's just talk
about it and in those check-ins the
stuff that would otherwise feel too
minor to bring up day-to-day because
it's like oh it's minor it's like not
bring that up it's like those little
things there a good chance to bring
those little things up and to discuss
them in the in the light of day and
usually we find that like having having
a couple of days distance from it like
when the thing if if the thing is very
big we'll discuss it when it happens but
if it's not you know we'll discuss it in
a relationship review over dinner at
like a nice place like I'm really
curious here yeah who adds to the notion
document and when so uh we so we it's a
shared notion workspace where we're both
on it and when we know it's a review
date so Monday so like every other
Monday is we try and do that's the
review time in reality it ends up being
like once every 3 weeks or so um so one
of us will take the iPad or the laptop
or the phone worst case scenario and
then if it's a laptop or an iPad I'll
type because I type faster if it's a
phone we'll just sort of pass it around
and take turns because phones annoying
but we find so we we've got like the
notes stretching back the last two years
cuz we've been together for 2 years now
and it's it's it's really nice looking
back and we sort of like note down any
sort of major disagreement we have we
call it a gate like you know there was I
don't know France gate and like tenie
gate and you know stuff like that where
it's like oh it's interesting to look
back on these big arguments that we had
and like the Le the takeaways from them
to make the relationship better so
interesting and then is there a
conclusion to each question so if you
say you know you said this to me in the
Kitchen last week and it really irked me
because it triggered me in this way do
you then write a conclusion next to it
or anything uh we write action points
action points yeah it's like in future
this is the thing like there was one
time we went on holiday together I
thought it was going to be a working
holiday because I was like hey I've got
I've got my book deadline this is a work
holiday she was like cool you know that
makes sense turns out my definition of
work holiday is I work 14 hours a day
and we we grab dinner together her
definition of a work holiday is we work
for 4 hours in the morning and then we
go go sightseeing we realized that like
5 days into the holiday and so our
action point from after the conversation
and that was okay before every holiday
we're just going to align on
expectations I was I was talking to Mark
Manson a a few weeks ago in LA and he
was like cuz he traveled around the
world with his fiance and he was like oh
man the main thing is just expectation
alignment bro that's that's what Moog
out at the thing that episode that I did
with the first one with moad taught me
so clearly and profoundly he said we're
happy when our expectations of how our
life is supposed to be going are met and
from that you can juuce we're unhappy
when our expectations of how our life is
supposed to be going are unmet so met
expectations equals the billionaire in
Mayfair getting a medium rare steak when
that was what she or he
ordered unmet expectations would be he
ordered or she ordered medium rare and
it came I don't know
bloody like it doesn't matter the fact
that you're in a a super bougie Mayfair
restaurant getting a you know Kobe beef
A5 wagu steak unmet
expectations you get unhappiness and you
go to Botswana where I was born hot ball
AR
expectations met for some of the people
back in that in the village that I was
was born in um the
objective situation matters less than
the subjective meeting of expectations
unmet expectations in work in your team
members in your relationship in yourself
will will result in unhappiness and
that's so important to understand
because then you can influence it you
can work on as it relates to yourself
This is why gratitude is so powerful
gratitude is for me it's like an
adjustment of one's
expectations um I I have this really
fond memory of getting I'm not sure if
I've Shar this on the podcast before or
somewhere else of this fun memory of I
didn't get on a plane and fly other than
flying from Africa to the UK until I was
like 21 so we didn't do holidays in our
family the money wasn't there and I
remember getting on that plane when I
was 21 years old with my business part
at the time flying to Thailand and
economy and just being captivated by
this concept of being in this tinan and
we were going to attempt to fly to
Thailand and I'm looking at the like
safety manual I'm like it's amazing it's
so such an incredible experience I was
so happy on that flight fast forward
fight fast forward 5 years I'm flying 50
weeks a year in 2019 F flying business
in first class and all I'm doing is
rushing on the plane throwing my bag up
and pulling my laptop out as fast as I
can before it takes off so I don't lose
Wi-Fi and then that day I encountered
the lady next to me on the plane he's
probably on like a honeymoon or
something she's like putting on the
slippers and she's going Dam Dave Dave
look at this catalog and they give you
champagne and she's picking up and she's
sipping it and she's old
me and she's experiencing the joy that I
used to experience when my expectations
were exceeded and nothing has changed in
my life other than my expectations have
increased yeah and with that out the
door has gone my joy so what I can do
now and what I do now is when I get on
the plane just before I step in I touch
the top of the plane and I take a moment
before I step on and just remind myself
of the absurdity that I I'm I'm getting
in this plane we're going to fly it
somewhere and I get to sit in this comfy
chair that reclines and when they bring
over the sh that's so incredible you can
influence your joy if you manage your
expectations and you know as it relates
to relationship the curse
of the source of all unhappiness and
relationship is unmet
expectations that's one you could do
that something about that yeah we need
to compare more notes on this
relationship thing there I'll send you
my uh my review template
yeah um final thing is how so to what
extent do you get criticism and how do
you cope with it all the time you're a
very public figure I think like with
especially with the Dragon's Den stuff
you kind of became more mainstream than
like
a personal Improvement business podcast
would normally get you it's an
occupational hazard my friend said to me
bigger the podcast gets I look over at
Rogan and what he's been
yeah and I go wow
uh it's yeah it's a lot like what
Rogan's been through I just could
imagine what anyone going through but
it's an occupational hazard and with the
claps comes the booze and and all that
stuff and I think the important thing is
doing everything you can to stay true to
yourself because then in the context of
any feedback whether it's positive or
negative you're anchored to something
that Mak sense you're anchored to your
own like
your own certainty in your intentions
and your values and why you do what you
do so even when we put out an episode
with Mo G out on the podcast about
artificial intelligence yeah and I get I
got like significant criticism for that
because um can be seen as scare
mongering oh
so a lot of people thought it was scare
mongering or clickbait or whatever else
um I believe in the message I believe in
what we said what we did and I know it's
coming from a good place so when we
receive that that critical feedback um I
can I can receive it um knowing that we
acted in line with um our own personal
Integrity if that makes sense so that is
the pursuit is like making sure why
you're doing what you're doing is is
true to yourself because then it's
easier to um proceed forward regardless
of
feedback
so what do you tell yourself like like
if you see something on Twitter or
something like do you do you feel this
thing initially and do you tell yourself
a story or like how how does that go it
depends it depends it depends what the
feedback is
so when Dragon's Den airs um you'll get
like a lot of people saying a lot of
things and I think at the start I would
I was more tuned into it I was more
tuned into like reading the tweets as
time has gone on I've realized that I
need to put systems and processes in
place that you as you'd call it to make
sure that stuff doesn't infiltrate my
pieace which me for me means don't read
stuff don't search stuff friends don't
send me stuff haven't searched my name
in any search engine or any way you can
search yourself in about a year now um
and trying to focus on the feedback that
you know is whether it's critical or
positive the feedback you know is
potentially valuable um
as much as you can yeah and I this
practice is more increasingly important
as like you reach more people yeah
knowing where to look for feedback and
knowing where not to look for feedback I
guess
so but does it sting I mean like of
course like I'll I I could open up a
comment section on like my own Instagram
and someone says something um
and you your your initial instinct is to
argue with the thing to try and like
argue with the thing or to understand or
to maybe win them over But as time has
gone on the distance between
experiencing seeing the thing and it my
exper my response and emotion to it has
reduced um which means that I can see
something and go that's not true like I
saw an article that said I was said um
Steve is going to release a line of
boxer shorts with his name on it and I
remember like someone had sent it to me
people don't send me stuff because they
know just not to send me stuff like cuz
we're just trying to keep focused here
thinking I'm going to releas a line of
box of shorts with my name on it and
they're like yeah you registered the
trademark for the Diary of a CEO and one
of the categories in which my team had
registered it was like clothing so the
like the newspaper ran with a story that
I was coming out with a a underwear line
like a box like a boxer short underwear
line with my name on it and you read
that and then you like understand that
that's gone out into the world and
people believe that now that coming out
with boxy shorts with my name on them um
and that it will influence people but
you also reflect and go there's nothing
I can do about that and that is okay it
is it comes with the territory and the
choice I have here is to completely
remove myself from the universe and go
to Barley and like where I love love to
go um or to carry on doing what I love
to do and the choice I make is I want to
carry on doing what I love to do
brilliant stepen I think that's a great
place to end this just wanted to say
firstly thank you for being gracious and
being interviewed on the Pod sitting in
that seat and I think also like you know
your work is just so inspirational to me
to my team to basically everyone I know
we sort of share the podcast episodes
around when the Vlog started we were all
sort of like watching that together
because it's so inspiring seeing what
you're building and the huge impact that
you're able to have but I think on top
of that like there was there was one
comment when you know you and I were
both speaking in charer in the UAE a few
months ago a year ago something like
that and you came and joined me and
Gordon my videographer for breakfast and
he was saying afterwards that wow what a
Class Act Steven is because you were
talking to him as much as you were
talking to me and normally with like
celebrities and stuff they they they'll
ignore like the team members you know
like Gordon's been in in a bunch in a
bunch of situations where the
videographer is kind of invisible and
just the fact that you're so gracious
with everyone around you I'm feeling
emotional saying this is weird it's just
so impressive it's it's so admirable and
yeah just wanted to say thank you you're
so sweet I I mean I don't know what to
say um but but yeah I mean thank you so
much for saying that I
um yeah thank you for saying that I'm
trying my best you know I'm trying my
best to to be a good person and I I'm
not I'm not always great at that like
I'm not I sometimes let myself down I
think about ways I reacted or days where
I'm I'm tired and I I I didn't show up
in the way I want to but I'm trying my
best because it really matters to me
what you just said trying my best to
leave more people with that feeling that
you you know your videographer was left
with so thank you for that CU I do give
myself a hard time about it sometimes
you know like where I am in my life now
it's like it's like I realize that
everyone I meet I'm meeting everyone
they
know do you understand what I'm saying
man so the girl that stopped me this
morning as I was going into the office
to tell me about quitting her job
like that
um it really matters that I'm patient
with her in that moment and that I
listen to her and make her feel you know
as best as I possibly can and it and
honestly it feels like it does feel like
a
responsibility and it's a responsibility
I want to meet but I I know I'm like I'm
human so I sometimes I'll fall short
it's a new responsibility you know go
back 10 years and and no one would have
cared if I I'd done that
either way and they also would never
have told anybody if I did that so it's
a new responsibility it's one I want to
meet and it's one that I know is
important um and it's a Fant honestly
it's such a privilege that people care
like such a privilege that someone would
care to stop you and say something nice
or to they would care that you join them
or they'd want you to join their
breakfast in the same way that we were
saying like it's a privilege that you
asked me to be on like to give you a
quote for your book or
whatever I hope I never lose
that nice thank you I appre appreciate
you so much what you do is incredible
and the way you conduct yourself is a
with the the grace you conduct yourself
is a bar that I would like to meet so um
thank you for having me on it's an honor
that you wouldd have me on and yeah your
team a reflection of how wonderful you
are so as is usually the case so thank
you and thank you for reading the books
because good books you know no but thank
you for that and you're one of those
people that because I've not had much
feedback on the book yet I'd love to
know like that's why I asked you the
question like what do you like about
them which one you prefer I'd love to
know more of that off camera so I'll
send you my annotations oh please you
have to take this
one all right good stuff thank you so
much thank you bro all right so that's
it for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye